Adam, could you move this back a little
bit just so I can see the
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the book of fasting
in the chapter regarding the pillars of
fasting.
We mentioned that fasting has how many
pillars? Two. The first pillar
intention. Second pillar, refraining
from anything that will compromise a
person's fast. And how many things will
break a person's fast?
Five or six, depending on how you count
them. So, we mentioned the first two,
eating or drinking anything
purposely.
We did about three days about eating and
drinking purposely. Remember
food and drink
go
in the Arabic language in any language
food and drink
they go
down the throat.
So really that is the chief
path of food and drink. We mentioned
that if a person were to take something
that supplements food and drink, not a
part or a portion of food and drink like
a vitamin shot or
what do you call it insulin or
anything that. This will
not break a person's fast. It has to
take the place of food and drink.
Meaning if you didn't eat or drink
anything and you only had this, it would
it would keep you alive, right? an
IV for hydration, a tube that you
get fed through straight into the
stomach.
However, anything else will not break a
person's fast. So for instance a u
suppository
a suppository suppository goes in the
the rectum right it's usually medicine
or something of that sort this will not
break a person's fast why because it's
not food or drink and suppositories yes
were around in the prophet's time sai
wasallam and yes they did administer
medicine through the rectum via the
rectum. the point is is that these
are the parameters of food and drink.
But something that does not take the
place of food and drink entirely. This
will not break a person's fast. So any
injections will not take a person's fast
again unless it takes the place of food
and drink. oftent times you know
there are a lot of questions that come
up. These are general guidelines. At the
end of the day if a person has a
particular question, a particular issue,
right? Then they are to take it to a
person of knowledge and ask.
The third is as the author mentions
here.
That is that a person induces himself to
vomit.
A person induces himself to vomit. What
does that mean?
Well, has the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam ever done that? Yes, he has
induced himself to vomit on multiple
occasions. The companions as well. And
as a matter of fact, inducing
oneself to vomit is one of the
prophetic remedies for certain
ailments.
So
if a person were to, you know, stick his
fingers into his gag reflex to to vomit
or do anything to make himself vomit,
this will break a person's fast.
However, if it comes on on its own and a
person throws up or vomits without
the person inducing it himself, it will
not break his fast. A person may then
ask the question, what's the difference?
Why is there a difference between a
person inducing himself to vomit and
vomit
overwhelming a person until they do?
What's the difference? Why does this
break the fast and this does not? Well,
first of all, because the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam made a distinction.
The evidence for this, as the author
states,
[Silence]
was
lacking cathedral.
[Silence]
The author says and inducing oneself to
vomit.
However, if a person is overcome by the
urge to vomit and does so without
him making himself vomit, inducing
himself to vomit, then he does not have
to make up that day and fast and he does
not have to pay a kaf. In other words,
his fast is true and he is to continue
fasting unless he needs to break his
fast for illness or what have you. Then
he cites the evidence for this. It's an
evidence which is collected by and
Abu D and Maja in their within
an an authentic chain of narration on
the authority of Abi
who narrates that the prophet Sam
said
whomever is overcome by the urge to
vomit and then does so then there is no
make upon him. They don't have to
make that day up. And whoever induces
himself to vomit, then he is to make
that day up. Why would he make the day
up? Because the fast is invalid. Because
it breaks a person's fast.
You know, sometimes people will wonder
why would you make yourself vomit?
But you know, this is actually a common
thing. , most people actually have
this. Say you have something bad for
sahul. You grabbed something and it was
a little bit dubious, but you went ahead
and and and ate it or drank it and then
you started feeling sick, right? Well,
the first
recourse in the prophet's medicine sai
was to empty the body of whatever is
ailing the person. So that is usually by
three methods, three things. Emptying
the stomach, emptying the bowels and
then drinking a lot of water. This is
how the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam remedied that in his sunnah. So
a person may make himself vomit. This
doesn't break a person's
woo.
There's a narration in
on the authority of
in which he narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
made himself vomit
and then he made wudoo.
Notice notice the narration. He made
himself vomit
and then he made wudoo.
He didn't say make woo after vomiting.
He didn't instruct that. This is
something that he did. So the most that
could be taken from this narration is
that it is preferred that a person make
wudoo after vomiting but it does not
invalidate a person's wudoo doesn't
affect a person's woo vomiting if it is
self-induced will break a person's fast
if it is not then it will not break a
person's fast let's say a person has a a
an upset stomach
you Oh, they have an upset stomach. They
have a stomach ache. Is this a valid
reason to break your fast?
And we talked about this in depth. So,
let's go ahead and try.
Everybody, a lot of people are having
this little thing in the back of their
mind say, "No, of course not. This is
Ramadan. Push through it. Power through
it." Right? What is the point of laying
around in agony?
What does this achieve exactly?
Right? Or a person gets a headache, a
very bad headache. They need to take
medicine. And so because it's Ramadan,
they just lay around in agony for hours
waiting for the clock to roll over on on
me. What have we achieved by doing this
exercise?
absolutely nothing. These of course are
valid reasons to break a person's fast
and the companions broke their fast for
way less than this. This kind of
extremism
oftent times
makes us take on burden that Allah
didn't put on us.
Right? Allah said in the verses of
fasting where did he what did he anchor
the rulings of fasting in? Remember we
have a number six or seven
verses about the purpose of fasting
and the legislation of fasting and so
forth. He anchored all of these rulings
on fasting in
which principle
Allah desires ease for you and he does
not desire difficulty. Therefore, if you
are experiencing
abnormal difficulty, notice the word
here, abnormal, unusual
difficulty. If we had a thousand people,
one person would have this level of
difficulty. the rest would have
discomfort.
Then fasting is not for you on that day,
right? And some of the companions tried
to power through things and the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam deterred them
from that and discouraged that. One time
the companions were with the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam traveling
and they were in the caravan and
suddenly he noticed a group of people
standing around someone looking at
something something was happening. So he
went over to see what was happening and
there was a man there who was
unconscious or senseless laying on the
ground and they were around him fanning
him and he said what's going on with
him? What happened? He inquired. They
said
he's fasting.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
fasting during travel is not part of
it's not part of righteousness.
But he traveled and fasted, didn't he?
So what do we understand the ver the
narration to mean?
traveling and this kind of fasting is
not part of righteousness. This is not
righteousness.
Crippling yourself for the daytime of
fasting, this doesn't accomplish
anything. And as a matter of fact, all
it does is associate
negativity with the worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so, yes, these are valid reasons to
break your fast, whether it be
stomach or headache or some kind of
unusual issue. What about pain? Let's
say a person has a toothache. Let's say
a person throws his back out and they
need to take a muscle relaxer or
something to ease this pain. Is this a
valid reason to break your fast? Yes.
Yes. I want you all to get used to this,
right? Because the old style of
suffering
and associating suffering and Allah's
obedience, these are not the same thing,
right? Obedience
is much better than sacrifice.
This is a principle. Obedience
is far more virtuous than sacrifice.
You're not asked to sacrifice all kinds
of abnormal things. You are required to
obey, right? Whether it be for travel,
whether whether it be for illness,
whether it be for pain, whe something
that is out of the ordinary.
, let's say a person is working
and they're working a very difficult job
that is abnormally difficult and they
are so thirsty, so hungry or weak that
they are on the verge of of
unconsciousness or senselessness.
This isn't illness, is it? This isn't
travel, is it? Does it jive with
does that and Allah desires ease for
you? Do those two things go together?
No. A person breaks his fast in this
instance.
This is the fatwa of the major scholars
of Islam.
some some I remember once a young
man asked and this was a question
that was directed to the major
scholars in Mecca and in the u
in the malis of you know
that a young man was working and he had
become so thirsty
that he was unconscious or almost
unconscious
and he said you know what should can a
person break his fast they said of
course you break your fast where did
they get this from a person may look at
the sunnah and say didn't the companions
have hard work in their time yes then
why isn't it mentioned there it is
it goes goes without saying of course
it's mentioned right this is an abnormal
incident this is an incidental thing
it is outside of the realm of normaly
therefore when these kinds of abnormal
things happen person may break his fast
and I've I've witnessed myself instances
in New York City when I was there where
the ambulance would come during the
month of Ramadan three three or four
times to pick people up. Why? Because
they're fasting and they have diabetes
and they went into a diabetic coma
trying to power through the day. Who
achieve what did we achieve by this
exercise,
right? I'll end with this. There's a
narration whereb Abbas
and this is to kind of
drive home
the
understanding that obedience is superior
to sacrifice.
a man, an old man was walking
and he had his two sons that he was
leaning on and he was walking and this
was in the caravan going to
in the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's Hajj. So of course when he
made Hajj in the ninth year after Hijra
he made this Hajj you know thousands of
companions accompanied him and he came
upon a man that was elderly and he had
his two sons and he was walking and kind
of hobbling along between his sons.
And so he asked them he asked him
what's what is he doing? What's what's
up with this guy? Of course, he didn't
say, "What's up with this guy?" But in
our language, what's up with this guy?
Right?
And so they said,
"Oh, messenger of Allah, he has vowed
to make Hajj walking. He's not going to
write anything. He's going to go walking
to Hajj." And so the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam. Imagine what he said. He said,
he said, "Right.
Allah does not need you or your
suffering or this walking that you're
doing." What does that mean? That means
that just obey. Don't sacrifice
unnecessarily. Don't be a martyr and
exaggerate the commands of Allah. The
same one that commanded you to fast is
the same one that commanded you to break
your fast in these circumstances.
I'm walking to Hajj. I'm not going to
ride. Who benefits from this? What is
who has benefited from this exercise?
No one. It's certainly not benefiting
Allah.
right? A man will be brought on the day
of judgment and he will be asked
Muslim. He will be asked
[Silence]
A man will be brought on the day of
judgment and asked, "If you had the
earth's fill of gold right now, would
you give it to ransom yourself from
punishment?" And he will say, "Of
course." You will say, "I desired of you
much less than that." But you insisted
on shik.
You insisted on polytheism. You insisted
on superstitions. You insisted on extra.
You don't have to sacrifice. All you
have to do is obey. Right? If you're
sick, break your fast. Make it up. Very
easy. Suffering is not a component of
fasting.
[Arabic recitation]